[Music]
ashley's with us in houston texas hi
ashley what's up ashley
hey
um okay so
how are you guys um thanks for taking my
call i had a couple of questions or just
one major question i guess i just wanted
some general guidance a little bit about
me
i'm 28
um
i'm a christian god saved me from drug
addiction back in 2015
i was raised by addicts
so money has been
a huge hurdle for me
um thankfully i don't really have a ton
of debt or anything
i've never had a credit card i've tried
but i've never
been given any lines of credit um
what's your core question
so my core question is um basically
wealth in general and building
um financial stability
is a foreign language
it feels so out of reach it feels like
there's a veil between me and this other
reality
where people
live
securely yeah you don't you know it
it feels like a foreign language
yeah all i've ever known is financial
insecurity i mean we moved at least once
a year my whole life the bills were
never paid lights getting turned off all
the time and um
god has been good as an adult he's you
know provided he's given me a lot of
things but i find myself
not i've never been able to
i've never been able to
save any money ever yeah john yeah i
always seem to get into some type of
hole okay so
here we go so i'm gonna jump into it
what you're describing you're describing
the poverty mindset right as though this
this air that you've been breathing for
for your whole life right
i want to give you a couple of things
that
can can rattle that cage for you okay
here's the first one you got to change
your ecosystem and environment and
sometimes that means moving that often
means the people you hang out with and
who you get wisdom from
it's a veil because you don't know those
people and i want you to go find
somebody at your church that will have
coffee with you or a couple of them or
three or four of them women who are 10
or 15 years ahead of you or some guy
running a company that will sit down
with you after church one day on sunday
and talk to you
but i want you to get to know those
people and it makes things much more
tangible and they talk in different ways
and they spend their money in different
ways the second one is often when we
grow up with all almost all when you
grow up with addicts
the idea of a relationship
is a equals pain because you've been
hurt repeatedly by those people who are
supposed to love you
and what i want to tell you is the only
way to heal and move forward is through
other relationships so you're going to
have to practice being in a relationship
with people sometimes you need a good
counselor for that it sounds like you've
been through a lot of addiction work and
lots a lot of addiction healing
but that's going to be a group of
friends a group of women that you meet
with regularly to do life with and it's
going to be low-fi stuff like let's go
get coffee so hang out the room you're
sitting in with these ladies you won't
feel like you fit in yes you'll feel
weird and that's okay
lean into that you tell them hey i feel
weird in here it's okay just it feels
awkward because it is because you don't
know how they think and they all seem to
think alike and you don't think like
they think and what you're trying to do
is change your thinking right and that's
that's that's how you do it and here's
the third become who you hang around
with here's the third big one
often when you especially when you grow
up with addicts and you grow up in
poverty
everything is about just getting to the
next day and the next day and the way to
lift that mindset is to start thinking
in
two months six months two years five
year plans and it's like going to the
gym you can do a really hard workout you
look at your body the next morning and
really nothing's changed but you go
again and you go again and you go again
and then six months eight months ten
months later you feel better you walk
better and so it's getting somebody that
can walk alongside you with this
wealth journey i'm gonna keep a budget
every month even though i'm only getting
10 bucks and the next month it's going
to be 20 bucks i'm going to save i'm
going to follow this budget i'm going to
slowly over time practice shifting my
life and i'm going to keep going and
keep going and keep going and write it
down and start saying
not in some weird positive affirmation
way but you're changing your identities
what you're doing it's exactly right i
grew up as an addict you're saying
i'm a young christian who's learning how
to build wealth and who's free
and i'm free of addiction and just write
that down because that's all true that's
true it's not some weird positive
affirmation it's just the truth that's
true and just speak that the power of
the tongue is amazing hey a great book
to pick up is glass castles you'll laugh
your way through it